right and what a better way to start the
show than by diving straight into the
colorful world of mario and the rapids
this latest adventure mario plus rabbids
sparks of hope is set to release on
october 20th on nintendo switch before
we catch up with the game's creative
director davide soliani let's take a
quick look
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
a few months ago we gave you an
exclusive on mario plus rabbit's sparks
of all
showcasing the game's unique mix of
turn-based combat
real-time action
and open exploration
we also did a deep dive on our unique
team of heroes
i want to thank you so much for your
tremendous feedback
and i know
you now want to see more gameplay
so today we are back to show you for the
very first time a first look at one of
the quests from the game
including a special battle that we took
great pleasure
in crafting
hello everyone i'm faye associate
producer welcome to this new video about
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
today our heroes travel to terraflora in
their quest to save the sparks
this green and usually flurry planet is
struck by a drought caused by curses
malevolent influence
[Music]
go now
[Music]
to help the planet blossom again mario
and his friends must reach the top of
the volcano to get there they will have
to find their way to the central station
and take the wiggler train
terror flora like all the planets of
mario prescribing sparks of hope it's
packed with secrets collectibles to
gather puzzles to solve and wacky end
pieces to talk with
with the help of people heroes can
interact with the environment in various
ways to uncover secrets or reveal hidden
paths to new zones
there are many interesting places to
visit and secrets to discover on
terraflora
giant trees lush plains and hidden caves
but let's get back on track
we have a train to catch
[Music]
all aboard
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hmm
[Music]
the weavier has been enraged by cursa
and we must stop it before it destroys
the train
mario and his friends will face numerous
enemy archetypes on the battlefield each
with specific strengths and weaknesses
we need to prepare accordingly
let's speak bowser first his huge health
stats will allow him to sustain heavy
damage
rabbit rosalina's signature technique
will be key to neutralize enemies while
the other heroes focus on the darkness
eyes will keep mario and the team to
take advantage of his great mobility
skills
now the sparks there are dozens of
sparks you can pair with new heroes they
will grant elemental damage resistances
help control battlefield and much more
ethering will help robert rosalina
getting behind enemy lines to wreck
havoc
we're done prepping so now is the time
to fight
let's activate mario spark aquanox to
gain additional splash damage
thanks to the splash effect mario can
push the ooze out of the train why did
he destroy the electric barrel with his
second attack
[Music]
rabbit rosalina can finish the ooze off
[Music]
while browser takes advantage of the
large attack radius of his bauzouka to
destroy two darkness eyes at the same
time
fast forward new enemies are spawning
behind us
we must get rid of them quickly
let's use mario spark glitter to lure
those enemies out into the open before
triggering mario's signature ability
hero side
[Music]
it's time for bowser to get his revenge
his landing damage ability
combined with the devastating power of
zephyr break his chocolate spark and
mario's support fire will make short
work of this group of enemies
teamwork and synergies are key to gain
the upper hand in battle
now that the back of the train is clear
we must reach the locomotive to destroy
the darkness eyes on the wiggler's back
this won't be easy as the lone walls
will react by shooting any moving hero
coming into range
they inflict heavy damage to bowser
thankfully exospheres his shield spark
absorbs some of the damage
[Music]
brute force won't make it here it's time
for a stealthy move with rarity rosalina
her spark ethering can turn her
invisible allowing her to approach the
long walk safely
now that we are close to them we can use
her signature technique and neutralize
them momentarily
this will allow mario to approach safely
and focus on the darkness eyes
[Music]
a few more turns have passed only two
darkness eyes remain but new powerful
enemies have spawned and even bowser
cannot withstand their powerful attacks
we have only two heroes left and the
last darkness eyes are far out of a tech
range
but mario can count on his iconic stump
attack and jump from one enemy to the
other before delivering the final blow
this is it the wiggler is defeated and
our heroes can resume their journey i
hope you enjoyed this very special
battle that's all for now
i hope you also enjoyed seeing an old
friend from nintendo in there
this was only a first taste of our new
take on combat it has intuitive gameplay
with huge tactical possibilities
thanks to the multiple combination of
sparks and ingredients available in the
game
anyone can create combos as marvelous as
they are powerful
the release is almost there and we are
hard at work to polish our game and
deliver the best mario plus rabbits
experience on october 20.
we cannot wait for you all to discover
this brand new adventure
and that's not all
we have one more big thing to reveal
this cosmic journey will not stop at
lunch we have so many wild ideas that we
want to explore in the coming year it is
a bit early to announce all of it
but i couldn't resist to give you a
small peak of what is to come
our post-launch plans include three dlcs
and the third one
will even introduce a new special
playable hero for me as a creator and
for many at the studio it's a dream come
true to have him
going in an adventure with our dear
rabbit heroes
[Music]
i hope you will like the biggest
surprise of our season pass
thank you
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]